Und.
Quantencomputer reagieren sehr empfindlich auf Rauschen –
Störungen, die Fehler verursachen
bei ihren Berechnungen. Aber neue Forschungsergebnisse zeigen,
dass IBMs verrauschte Quantencomputer exakte klassische Methoden erreichen
und in verifizierbaren Bereichen anspruchsvolle klassische
Näherungsverfahren übertreffen – sowohl in verifizierbaren
als auch in unverifizierbaren Bereichen –
bei einem anspruchsvollen Simulationsexperiment.
Wie machen sie das? Sie nutzen eine spezielle Technik,
um mit dem Rauschen umzugehen,
das in Quantensystemen auftritt – sie nennt sich Fehlerminderung.
Mit der Fehlerminderungstechnik,
die in diesem Experiment eingesetzt wurde, führen wir unsere Berechnungen durch
und erhöhen dabei das Rauschen schrittweise.
Dann extrapolieren wir zurück auf null Rauschen.
Diese Arbeit bringt uns dem nützlichen Quantencomputing einen Schritt näher –
wir